[Musik]
Parteien zu gründen scheint der
politische Trend der Saison zu sein und
hat wohl in erster Linie eine Ursache
die geradezu provozierende
Selbstbeschäftigung der etablierten
Parteien ein gefundenes Fressen für all
jene die sich ohnehin zu höheren berufen
fühlen aber bis glaubten zu wenig
gewürtigt zu werden Wagenknecht und
Maßen welche Chancen haben neue Parteien
jetzt in der
phönixrunde
phöniixrunde herzlich Willkommen bei uns
meine Gäste im Studio heleneowski ist
bei uns seit Anfang des Monats
stellvertretende Chefredakteurin beim
Medienportal table Media davor lange
Jahre Redakteurin in der
parlamentsredaktion der Frankfurter
Allgemeinen Zeitung wolfr Weimer ist
Publizist und Verleger in seiner o Media
Group erscheinen zwei Magazine unter
anderem zwei Magazine European und
businesspk Sebastian Puschner ist
stellvertretender Chefredakteur der
Wochenzeitung Freitag und bei uns ist
der Politikwissenschaftler Gero
Neugebauer Herr Puschner haben wir da am
Wochenende einen neuen am parteihimmel
auf parteihimmel parteienhimmel muss man
ja sagen aufgehen sehen oder um buupt
sich die das Bündnis SAR Wagenknecht
doch letztendlich als Sternschnuppe ja
das wird es werden die kommenden Monate
oder vielleicht noch ein bisschen
längere Zeit zeigen wie schnell dieser
Stern wieder erlischt im Moment strahlt
er der Parteitag lief ebenso glatt wie
alles bisher was diese Partei eigentlich
so auf den Weg gebracht hat aber ob das
ein auch nur mittelfristiges Projekt ist
das lässt sich von heute aus gesehen
noch nicht beantworten weil man
Parteigründungen hat's ja in der
Geschichte der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland immer wieder gegeben im
Laufe der Jahrzehnte erfolgreich oder
auch erfolglos aber was sagt uns das
jetzt wenn sich diese Neugründungen
gerade häufen ja das sagt uns dass wir
in einem defining moment unserer
Republik unser Demokratie stehen wenn
die politische Mitte erodiert und
geschwächt ist und die Ränder in dieser
Dimension zuneh wie wir das Moment
erleben dann definiert sich unsere
Republik neu dass eine
rechtspopulistische Partei
größer ist als alle Regierenden
Koalitionsparteien das haben wir noch
nicht erlebt dass eine Kanzlerpartei nur
14% hat haben wir auch noch nicht erlebt
also die Zentrifugalkräfte der Republik
sind gewaltig und ich fürchte dass wir
am Ende dieses Jahres Wahlergebnisse
haben werden und dann eine andere
Republik frauowski jetzt ist ja noch
eine andere Partei kommende Partei im
Fokus der Öffentlichkeit noch nicht
gegründet noch in den Geburtswehen wenn
man so will ist auch noch gar nicht ganz
sicher ob sie tatsächlich als Partei
gegründet wird ich rede von der
werteunion sollte sich die tatsächlich
Gründen als Partei jetzt in diesem Jahr
kann man sich dann in der CDU entspannt
zurücklehnen und sagen Gott sei Dank die
querelanten die sind rechts
raus nein also es gab natürlich eine
gewisse Erleichterung als Hans Maen vor
einigen Tagen seine Mitgliedschaft bei
der CDU beendet hat das wollten ja viele
ihn aus der Partei ausschließen jetzt
ist es auf diesem Wege passiert trotzdem
ist natürlich wenn man an das alte
Diktum von Franz Josef Straus denkt
rechts der CDU darf es ke oder der CSU
darf es keine Parteien geben haben wir
jetzt schon die nochmalige Gründung
einer weiteren Partei die möglicherweise
kommt
die Prognose ist auch hier schwierig ich
habe meine Glaskugel nicht dabei aber am
Ende ist Hans-Georg marßen den ich noch
an seiner aus seiner Zeit als
verfassungssch
Präsident Kenner hat eine
Radikalisierung durchgemacht in den
vergangenen Jahren ist angetrieben von
seiner eigenen gekränkten Eitelkeit von
dass ist wirklich eine ein Rachefeldzug
den er macht gegen seine eigene Partei
eine unaufgearbeitete Kränkung die er
erfahren hat von Angela Merkel das ist
so sehr eigene Rechnung dass ich denke
wahrscheinlich ist es zu also noch mehr
als bei Sara Wagenknecht so dass ich
denke wer nur auf eigenem Ticket
unterwegs ist wird mutmaßlich mit seiner
Partei keinen Erfolg haben meine
vorsichtige heute gekränkte Eitelkeit
ist sicherlich eine wichtige Triebfeder
um politisch Karriere zu machen oder
Aufmerksamkeit zu erlangen Herr
Neugebauer sortiert sich unser
bisheriges Parteienspektrum komplett
neu jetzt der Verdacht auftaucht ich
wollte ein Seminar machen wollte ich nur
sagen das Parteiensystem spiegelt die
konfliktstruktur der deutschen
Gesellschaft wieder und die Konflikte
neben zu eine Polarisierung findet statt
und insofern ist es logisch dass in den
par Teilen in den bisher verschiedeneen
sozusagen leidthemen eigentlich immer
noch zusammengefügt kden konte
integriert werden konnen wie der Union
das jetzt auseinander geht die Linke
zerfällt und dass Parteien wie die
Sozialdemokraten die Grünen und die
Liberalen wahrscheinlich aus lauter
Angst es würde ihn es würde sie die
Regierung Kosten darauf verzichten diese
interne Auseinandersetzung zu machen man
kann sie dort sehen aber sie gehen nicht
so weit dass man da sagt da kommen jetzt
auch neue Parteien heraus aber im
Prinzip folgen die auch ein Gewissen und
das denke ich für die gilt für die
beiden letzt genannten persönlichen
Interessen das sind Ausgründung keine
ech Neugründung wir haben seit 2022 44
neue Gründung in der Bundesrepublik und
in der Liste bei der bundeswahlleiterin
sind 120 Parteien vermerkt jetzt wird ja
viel spekuliert dass müssen wir bei zwei
oder mehr Parteien tun die noch gar
nicht zu Wahlen angetreten sind den
Bündnis Sara wagenknicht den wenn ja
durchaus Erfolgchancen eingeräumt da
gibt's zwar unterschiedliche
Umfrageergebnisse bei der werteunion äh
weiß man noch nicht so genau ob es
überhaupt was wird und wie sie dann
abschneiden wird eher vielleicht nicht
so gut
äh worin liegt denn der Unterschied
zwischen diesen beiden Formationen ich
meine jetzt nicht inhaltlich sondern von
ihren Entwicklungsmöglichkeit auch von
ihrem Umfeld also ich glaube dass die
werteunion gar keine Chance hat in
diesem Jahr irgendwie eine
maßgebliche politische Rolle zu erringen
das liegt
zum einen an der Führungsperson die hat
kein Charisma und
auch keine Sympathiewerte das liegt aber
auch an der Positionierung wem die CDU
nicht rechts genug ist der hat ja AFD
und wem die AFD wiederum in diesem Feld
zurechts ist der hat die Freien Wähler
wo soll da Platz sein jetzt für eine
weitere kleine Gruppierung also ich
glaube die maßenpartei wird relativ
schnell in der Bedeutungslosigkeit
verschwinden anders bei Sarah
Wagenknecht sie ist eine
charismatikerin und sie
hat die Implosion der politischen Linken
hat sie natürlich aufgespürt und sie
kombiniert ich würde mal sagen das
schlechteste aus beiden Welten die
Migrationspolitik der AFD und die
Wirtschaftspolitik der linken und das
ist natürlich ein doppelter Populismus
und da hat sich schon Chancen ich glaube
aber nicht dass das jetzt über 10% geht
aber dass sie 3 4 5 6% bei den
Europawahlen holt das halte ich für
realistisch also ist der Unterschied
zwischen Stern und Sternschnuppe also
ich glaube dass der Unterschied zwischen
Wagenknecht und Maßen ist dass
magenknecht auf das immer wieder
angenommen wird nicht so sehr persönlich
getrieben ist die hätte genug zu tun und
ihr Mann im Saarland zu Hause würde sich
auch freuen wenn sie da sitzen würde mit
ihm nach Frankreich in Urlaub fährt ihre
Bücher schreibt oder so ich glaube das
ist schon ein ja ja ich weiß ich weiß
schon die Vermutung ist immer ist immer
ist immer schnell bei der Hand aber
tatsächlich ist der Unterschied zu ihrem
ersten Anlauf vor ein paar Jahren mit
dieser Sammlungsbewegung mit Aufstehen
derjenige dass sie jetzt etliche Leute
um sich geschart hat die zum einen
organisieren können die zum anderen
mobilisieren können und die zum dritten
durchaus politisch was antreibt und das
ist durchaus auch übrigens die Sorge vor
der politischen Entwicklungen und vor
den der Stärke der AFD das würde von
denen so laut nicht unbedingt jemand
sagen weil wenn das Kalkül AFD Wähler
sozusagen von dort zurück zu holen
aufgehen soll dann sollte man das
vielleicht nicht zu demonstrativ ins
Fenster stellen aber das ist ja genau
die die Frage oder der griffige Begriff
oder die griffige Formulierung ist ja
ist sind diese beiden Parteien je eigen
eine Alternative zur Alternative für
Deutschland also es verbindet sich ja
jetzt die Hoffnung mit dieser
insbesondere Bündnis saa Wagenknecht
Gründung dass sie
Wähler von der AFD abzieht und dass sich
der dieser Rand die zwei Extreme die
sich treffen
m so ausdifferenziert und zerstückelt
dass die eben dann der
AFD diese diese wahnsinnigen
Zustimmungswerte die sie jetzt hat
kaputt machen ich wä mir da nicht so
sicher dass diese Hoffnung aufgeht am
Ende hat man bedeutet mehr Auswahl im
Bereich des Populismus auch häufig mehr
Zustimmung also die Leute jetzt sagen
ich will nicht AFD weil mir das zu
rechts ist und die Linkspartei auch
nicht mehr und so weiter aber jetzt mit
Sarah Wagenknecht ist vielleicht eine
interessante Option insbesondere
interessanterweise bei älteren Männern
kommt Sarah Wagenknecht wahnsinnig gut
an
mobilisiert unglaublich in diesem
Bereich mit dieser Mischung auch auch
programmatisch aus die sogenannte
Friedenspartei in meinen Augen ist es ja
nicht redet sie nicht von Frieden
sondern fordert die Unterwerfung der
Ukraine aber aber sei es drum äh dieser
dieser europakritik die sich reinmischt
die der restriktive Kurs in der
Migrationspolitik diese ganze
antivokeness Agenda dieses ich bin für
den echten Arbeiter heute da also klingt
in manchen Dingen fast schon wie Gehard
Schröder in in seiner der ja auch
antivoke und kraftriegel der der
Arbeiter ist die Curry oder was war das
die currywur ne genau also so das
bedient sie alles sehr geschickt ich
kann nur sagen ich war am Wochenende
an einkaufen und neben mir stand ein
Herr der mich ansprach sagt ich kenne
sie ja und so weiter dann haben wir kurz
geredet und dann unterbrach er aber das
Gespräch und sagte tut mir leid er hatte
ein Kopfhörer auf und sagte tut mir leid
Sarah spricht jetzt ich muss zuhören und
dann dachte ich aha das ist wirklich
verbreitet gerade zu erfurchtsvoll
sprechen die Menschen über sie über die
phöniix App gemacht wir haben diesen
Parteitag ja ausfühlich das war pH
tatsächlich ja dafür sind wir ja auch
geschaffen worden her neubbauer wenn man
jetzt ä scheint sich da ja gerade auch
rechts einiges äh richtig zu
fragmentieren was ja unüblich war früher
war das immer auf der politischen linke
das linken das magenzeichen Freien
Wähler sind schon genannt worden die
haben ja eigentlich auch einen nicht
gerade leisen Parteivorsitzenden
neutralisieren sich die dann rechts so
dass quasi dieser Rechtspopulismus sich
gegenseitig da im Weg steht es geht ja
auch darum inwiew weit diese Parteien
jetzt im Laufe des Jahres ins
Europäische Parlament bzw in die drei
ostdeutschen Landtage einziehen
können also mit Sicherheit wird die
Union versuchen ihre
Integrationsfähigkeit zu verstärken
nicht umsonst hat sie dies Programm
gemacht das Programm das ja konservatien
grundzugck hat und möglicherweise einige
Menschen die wegen des ich sag das mal
so proletarischen Stils der afdptik oder
der Freien Wähler oder andonder dann
sagen nein dann gehe ich lieber doch
wieder Union wählen insbesondere auch
deshalb weil die bei bestimmten
politikfällern Europa beispielsweise
gerade die Union gilt als die
Europapartei schon eine andere
Perspektive haben äh aber auf der
rechten Seite ist das Problem
dass
dort insbesondere AFD es gelungen ist
die Migrationsfrage zu entscheidenden
zum entscheidenden politischen Thema zu
machen alles andere dieser Frage
unterzuordnen und auf der anderen Seite
die die Opposition auch die Union aber
auch vor allen Dingen die
Regierungsparteien es nicht geschafft
haben eine andere Erzählung dagegen
zusetzen für viele Anhänger der AFD ist
jetzt mal unabhängig davon ob sie den
Position also den rechten Position
zustimmen immer die Frage entscheidend
ist die Immigration zuständig für mein
oder verantwortlich dafür dass ich jetzt
Sorgen um meinen Wohlstand habe um meine
soziale Existenz um die Z um meine
Zukunft oder die sondern die frag die
sagen und das kann alles so sein also
wie ich dann immer polemisch formuliere
der alte honeker Spruch vorwärts immer
rückwärts nimmer wird da umgedreht
rückwärts immer vorwärts nimmer und da
fühlen sie sich sicher aber es gibt eben
konservative die konservativ begreifen
als nicht wie Franz Josef Straus an die
Spitze des Fortschritts stellen um ihn
aufzuhalten sondern das was
bewahrenswert ist zu bewahren und das
andere zu entwickeln und diese
konservativen fühlen sich dann über auch
nicht bei Maßen zu Hause dondern die
werden dann zur Union gehen oder
möglicherweise auch zur Sozialdemokratie
aber dann kommt's auf an welches Thema
das ist nur die rechte ist zurzeit eher
ermuntert gerade aufgrund der Tatsache
dass die deutsche Gesellschaft sich
polarisiert und der rechte Flügel
gemessen an den beispielsweise
Umfragewerten welche Werte erreichen die
rechten Parteien also rechts von der
mittelparteien oder wie schätzen die
Befragten ihre eigene politische
Position ein die Gesellschaft neigt sich
mehr mehheitlich nach rechts und
insofern ist da die Geer größer was man
aus diesen Umfragen rauslesen kann was
man daav politisch für ein Kapital bei
Wahlen schlagen kann da kommen wir noch
dazu da gibt's auch interessanter
Entwicklungen migrationsthema schon
gefallen als Stichwort hat ja auch Sarah
Wagenknecht aufgenommen da ist ja gibt
es ja durchaus
erstaunliche Übereinstimmungen
jedenfalls für jemand der aus der linken
Seite kommt auch mit der AFD der
Parteitag da am Samstag den wir schon
angesprochen haben dieser
Gründungsparteitag der lief ja
erstaunlich
äh ruckelfrei ohne Chaos ohne freiwillig
unfreiwillige Komik was ja manchmal bei
politisch unerfahrenen oder
parteipolitisch unerfahrenen
passieren kann
zeigt das auch dass SAR wagench doch
vorhat oder eine Professionalität
entwickeln konnte vergleichen mit
anderen Versuchen Bewegung Aufstehen z.B
die ihr doch eine gewisse politische
Zukunft ermöglichen wird ja auf jeden
Fall also ich habe es ja schon gesagt
das war von Anfang bis Ende
durchchoreografiert von dem kleinen
Kreis der sich jetzt maßgeblich aber
nicht ausschließlich in diesem
erweiterten Parteivorstand ungefähr zwe
Dutzend Leute wiederfindet da gehört
sicherlich noch der eine oder die andere
außerdem dazu die Kandidatenliste war
vorbereitet das Programm wurde
einstimmig beschlossen und es gab ja
eben so gut wie keine Panne und bei den
kleinen wie so einer videoinspielung von
Justus Franz mit Grüßen im Namen des
Friedens und der Kultur die war als se
Oscar la spontan auf die Bühne stieg um
noch kurz zu ergänzen dass das jetzt
aber jusus freinz gewesen sein soll fast
auch schon choreografiert weil als dann
Laon zum ersten Mal auf der Bühne war
gab brandete natürlich der Jubel auf
aber interessant wenn man sich die
thematische Choreografie des des des
Parteitags ansieht ist dass das Thema
Migration so gut wie keine Rolle
gespielt hat es kam nicht vor und das
ist glaube ich schon auch Ausdruck von
sag ich mal ja eben nicht nur
Überlegungen sondern durchaus auch
Auseinandersetzungen im im Hintergrund
da gibt es sicherlich Leute die wollen
nicht als die antimigrationspartei
wahrgenommen werden das Europa
Wahlprogramm sagt klar was Sie wollen
nämlich äh Asylverfahren und
schutzprüfungsverfahren an den EU
Außengrenzen und außerhalb der EU
die ganze rassistische Rhetorik wie man
sie bei der AFD findet die findet man
bei dieser Partei nicht drum wäre ich da
ein bisschen vorsichtig immer gleich die
Parallele zu ziehen und rechts und links
da gleich zusetzen und ich glaube die
der der schweppen lag durchaus auf
einerseits der Sozialpolitik vor allem
auf der Friedens
und eben dem Votum dafür diesen
statischen Krieg in der Ukraine nicht
weiterzusetzen und und das ist glaube
ich mit das wichtigste auf der
Wirtschaft und das ist ja eigentlich das
Thema was viele in Deutschland umt darf
ich das aberind zwei Sachen gab's ein
AFD framing auffallend und zwar einmal
die mehrfach geäußerte Behauptung man
dürf ja in Deutschland seine Meinung
nicht mehr sagen also die Verengung des
meinungskorridors und dass Putin aus S
der BSW ja offenbar nichts mit dem
ukrainekrieg zu tun hat also das heißt
diese da gibt es schon eine sehr stark
Überschneidung auch mit mit ich glaube
auch dass das der Grund sein wird warum
die Bewegung von ihr an Größe und
Dynamik nicht gewinnen wird die haben
mehrere Probleme ein Problem ist das
Alter wer sich den Parteitag ang ich
fand es ziemlich greyheadmäßig also und
Oscar lafontain ist jetzt auch nicht die
Verkörperung der Jugendlichen Avantgard
er kann auch reden wie ein Jugendlicher
avangardist aber ist es halt nicht mehr
und die ganze Partei und auch die die
sie tragen deswegen war die Geschichte
hier von dem älteren Herren wirklich
symptomatisch es sind Leute und ich
glaube nicht dass politische Bewegung
die aus einem Impetus herauskommen wenn
sie nicht von der Jugend mitgetragen
werden definiert werden verkörpert
werden mileage haben also über längere
Strecke halten können das das sehe ich
als ein Problem an das zweite ist diese
russlandfrage ist ja nicht irgendein
Nebenthema also wir es ist ein
Massenmörder gerade dabei in Europa den
größten Krieg unserer Generation vom
Zaun zu brechen und hundertausende
Menschen in den Tod zu schicken und in
dem Moment zu sagen
wir sollten ihm uns andienen sein Gas
wieder kaufen und die Ukraine vergessen
das ist schon ein Punkt da glaube ich
auch dass viele Leute die sonst
vielleicht bei wirtschaftspolitischen
Fragen sagen hat sie vielleicht recht
bei diesem Punkt sagen nee also das
gehen wir einfach nicht mit na ich also
Herr Weimer ich bin ja inhaltlich ganz
bei Ihnen dass dass ich das auch
schrecklich finde aber die Wahrheit ist
dass es viel mehr Menschen in
Deutschland gibt die anders auf den
Ukraine Krieg blicken als als wir beide
und vielleicht auch die veröffentlichte
Meinung in Berlin
das kann man schon sehen an Umfragen zum
Thema Waffenlieferung das kann man ist
eine Erklärung dafür für das Zögern von
Olaf Scholz weil er weiß wie groß die
Zurückhaltung ist dieses Kriegstreiber
dieser K Kriegstreiber Vorwurf gegen den
Kanzler gegen die Außenministerin gegen
Robert habbeck das ist eine das ist ein
substanzieller Bestandteil unserer
Bevölkerung das ist sicherlich ein
Ursache von oder Folge von
Desinformation von vielen anderen von
einer im Osten noch Tiefs Sitz in
Russland Freundlichkeit von einem
Antiamerikanismus über die Gründe kann
man
vielfältig reden aber es gibt ein
Reservoir an an an Wählern die bisher im
Grunde wenn überhaupt nur von der AFD
angesprochen werden und von allen
anderen Parteien die in dieser Linie ja
alle durch die Bank relativ klar sind
ähm die SPD manchmal noch bei den
waffenfragen nicht ganz so klar
vielleicht wie die Grünen und die CDU
aber trotzdem relativ klar sind die
werden jetzt angesprochen von Sarah
Wagenknecht mit diesem framing Frieden
schaffen ähm und auch die älteren
Menschen ich ich sehe es ja wie sie eine
wirklich ein grauhaariger Parteitag und
gleichzeitig gibt es davon halt auch
relativ viele die auf diese ganze
vogness Jugendbewegung irgendwie eine
27-jährige Ricarda lang sagen die hat
überhaupt nichts gelernt keine
Ausbildung und so weiter was soll das
denn warum sollen solche Leute denn in
diesem Land was zu sagen haben die
fühlen sich auch abgeholt und
angesprochen von denen die ja heute
nicht mehr ältere Menschen sondern
reifere Menschen g aber wenn Sie das
nationale rtim und das sozialistische
zusammen fügen und und legen sich dann
noch vor die Füße des kremmels dann kann
ich mir nicht vorstellen dass das
wirklich mehr als 3 4 5% attraktiv ich
würde sagen leider ist sind es doch mehr
ja das ist kein Thema für das Wahlen
entscheidet also zumindest auf
landtagsebene der Landesebene
entscheidet das kriegsthema nicht die
Stimmenabgabe für BSW oder eine andere
Partei weil da weiß man das haut einfach
nicht hin und das zweit der zweite
Problem ist mit dieser
Positionierung frage ich mich mit wem
will sie eigentlich operieren wenn sie
ihre Ambitionen Regierungspartei zu
werden realisieren möchte da muss eine
Partnerin od Partner finden und ich sehe
keine von den Parteien von der AFD
abgesehen wo sie das machen könnte also
W ich vorsichig abgesehen davon dass ihr
Ego ist wahrscheinlich ihr schwer macht
sich in so eine Riege
einzuordnen aber sie denkt ja nicht an
Verantwortung und Machtübernahme sondern
sie denkt jetzt erstmal an maximale
Aufmerksamkeit natlich ich ich glaube
ein bisschen ich glaube das die Dinge
liegen so ein bisschen anders ich glaube
in den anderen Parteien gerade gerade in
ostdeutschen Landesverbänden in
Thüringen Brandenburg Sachsen wo dann im
Herbst gewählt wird da gibt es durchaus
schon Überlegungen ob denn dieses BSW
koalitionsfähig sein wird ein Michael
kretschm in Sachsen z.B macht sich da
bin ich ganz sicher seine Gedanken und
es gibt ja kein
unverbeieinbarkeitsentschluss und wie
Sie richtig sagen das entscheidet keine
Landtagswahlen und in Landesregierungen
und entsprechenden Koalitionen wird aber
auch nicht über Waffenlieferung in die
Ukraine entschieden oder über die
Zukunft der Europäischen Union drum
glaube ich dass die
Mehrheitsverhältnisse die wir wie in
Thüringen schon haben und in allen drei
Ländern haben werden durchaus diese
Partei eine Position bringen werden wo
es sich entscheiden muss ob sie regieren
will oder nicht sie trägt das Moment
sehr demonstrativ nach außen so würden
wir sofort machen könnte das zünglland
an der Wage werden könnte das zünglland
an der Wage werden wird ja jetzt auch
hinsichtlich dieser muss man auch sagen
sehr unsubstantiellen Umfragen also die
sagen nicht viel aus aber es gibt sie
und
auf Grundlage dessen wird ja schon
diskutiert also bischen zu FAZ wurde
Friedrich März empfohlen nicht zu
schnell
SAR Wagenknecht auszuschließen darf ich
noch einen Einwand erheben und zwar ich
glaube dass es zu kurz gesprochen ist
wenn man sagt dieses friedensthema
dieses Ukraine Thema spielt bei
Landtagswahlen keine Rolle weil es
indirekt eben schon reinspielt an ganz
verschiedenen in ganz verschiedenen
Bereichen bei den Energiepreisen die die
Leute immer noch nach wie vor umtreiben
wo dann eben der sehr schnell mit der
Forderung kommt warum kaufen wir nicht
wieder billiges russisches Gas und bei
der ganzen bei den ganzen
Verteilungskämpfen jetzt zunehm auch mit
dem mit dem Haushalt bei dem man eben
sich nicht mehr ohne Ende Verschulden
kann da gibt es ist kommt zunehmend die
Kritik müssen wir so viel Geld an die
Ukraine bezahlen so viel Geld für
Militär für die Ukraine ausgeben wenn
wir dann für unsere Leute hier im Land
kein Geld mehr haben und das sind alles
Dinge die die von bünd SAR wagenkn nicht
bedient werden die auch reinsickern bis
in die Landesebene oder kommunale Ebene
aber die zeitenwinde muss zurückgedreht
werden und das kann sie nicht
wir sagen mehr Parteien wir in
Deutschland jetzt haben umso leichter
kann es passieren dass wir in der
phönixrunde die ein oder andere
vergessen das wollen wir möglichst
verhindern deswegen Herr Puschner was
wird jetzt eigentlich aus der Partei DIE
LINKE ja da bin ich auch sehr gespannt
kann man die schon abschreiben gibt's
eine abragprämie drauf oder was wird
passieren na ja im Moment sind
hundertausende von Menschen in
Deutschland auf der Straße gegen die AFD
und ich würde mal sagen da sind sehr
viele dabei die eigentlich potenzielle
Wählerinnen und Wähler der Linken sein
könnten aber irgende schafft sie es in
aus diesem Schockzustand heraus noch
nicht wirklich das umzumünzen das
braucht Zeit Moment sieht's eher so aus
als würde sie zumindest bei den nächsten
Bundestagswahlen keine Chance auf den
Wiedereinzug haben aber bis dahin ist ja
noch ein bisschen Zeit unter
Umständen und man merkt diese Nervosität
auch beispielsweise an dem was gregar
gizi am Wochenende beim Landesparteitag
der Linken in in in Brandenburg gesagt
hat sozusagen 100 km oder 200 km
entfernt vom bsw teitag hat nämlich
gesagt er wünscht Sarah Wagenknecht dass
sich irgendein ganz schmieriger Typ in
diese Partei einklagt abgewiesen wird
man will nicht und das zeigt glaube ich
schon dass die Nerven blank liegen und
bei der Linken die Dinge nicht zum
besten stehen ähm ja ich glaube dass die
Tage der linke gezählt sind in der
deutschen Parteiengeschichte
ähm die Sacher Wagen nicht wird meiner
Meinung nach in die Geschichte eingehen
als die abresbne der der SED weil also
die Nachfolgepartei die Linke und da hat
sie dann auch eine wichtige Rolle
gespielt weil sie natürlich dekovriert
hat sozusagen was an an an der linken
versteinert war rückwärts gewandt war
nicht mehr offen war auch im auch im
Inneren Diskurs und und sozusagen sich
zurückgezogen hat in die letzten
Plattenbauten
Ostberlins und wenn wir heute die
Umfragen sehen dass die Linkspartei
jetzt bei 3% ist und in Westdeutschland
natürlich überhaupt keinen Boden mehr
findet ich glaube das wird sich bei der
Europawahl abbilden da wäht ganz
Deutschland und wenn man bei einer
flächendeckenden Wahl eine Partei wie
die Linke dann nur noch bei 2 3% hat
dann ist die Geschichte eben da für sie
zumal die Linke sich auch abwendet von
ihren alten Ideen sie will radikal
sozialistische ökologische Partei werden
das heißt sie wird ein Teil ihrer
Anhänger verlieren insbesondere in
aostdeutschen Ländern weil das keine
Linie ist die der Folgen können hat ja
schon und ja hat sie schon verlit auch
weit und viele verlassen ja die Partei
mit den Füßen voran sie ist ja nicht die
jüngste Partei also insofern ist die
Perspektive nicht besonders günstig und
wer dann in den westdeutschen Städten
noch links gewählt hat auf dem Lande war
sie schon lange nicht mehr präsent und
seit 2012 hat sie keine Zustimmung mehr
bekommen die es ihr erlaubt h zu sagen
das ist eine Perspektive da würde ich
auch sagen im Moment ja Sekte durchaus
möglich aber das was die Linke
repräsentierte ja ist Bestandteil dessen
was in der politischen Kultur der
Bundesrepublik zu Hause ist und insofern
wird sich dann irgendwann wieder jemand
finden der sagt organisieren wir neu
finden wir neu oder
die Grünen sagen na ja wir haben doch
noch ein linkelflügel oder die
Sozialdemokratie aber das ist wieesagt
wenn sich jetzt politische milies
auflösen lösen sich möglicherweise auch
parteienidentitäten auf also linker
Konservatismus das ist ja das was man
jetzt s wgen nicht zueignet meint
sozialpolitisch links kulturpolitisch
eher rechts aber diese klassische
politische gesäßgeographie früherer
Jahrzehnte was rechts und links ist geht
diese Gewissheit jetzt gerade verloren
ja ich glaube das beobachten wir schon
länger dass dieses
rechtslinkschema diese Lager nicht mehr
nicht mehr so richtig funktionieren
interessant ist ja bei der bei der
Linkspartei deswegen bin ich also auch
ich glaube dass sie keine Zukunft hat
aber interessant ist ja dass dieser
Streit der innerhalb der Linken über
Jahre gehte war ja zwischen den den Sara
wagenknechtflügel und den sogenannten
bewegungslinken die eigentlich mit den
Grünen konkurriert haben die in Berlin
Kreuzberg friedrichshein stark waren die
sehr stark auf das diese ganze vogeness
äh äh Gendern und ähnliches gesetzt
haben katja Kipping war ja die Gründerin
dieser Idee und das gab ja diesen
internen Streit ob man jetzt eigentlich
mehr an die Tradition auf dem Land eine
Art im Osten Ersatz für die
Sozialdemokratie Alternative sein will
oder in den Städten äh aktiv sein wir
und jetzt hat sich ja gerade der Flügel
abgespalten der
also der sagen der wagenknechtfügel der
eben in auf auf dem Land erfolgreich war
und jetzt haben wir noch eine Partei die
vielleicht und das ist ja natürlich die
Hoffnung mancher Linken in manchen
Städten in Berlin z.B noch erfolgreich
sein kann ich glaube nicht dass das
funktioniert ich glaube eine Partei die
über 5% kommen will kann nicht auf so
ein begrenztes fehlerreservoir zugreifen
aber da jedenfallsmal hätten sie die
jungen linken noch ja ich bin nämlich
auch gewundert über den Vorwurf des
versteinerzeins weil eigentlich ist ja
das diese moderne linke genau die die da
jetzt befreit ist von der Last
wagenknechts und irgendwie kommt sie
aber nicht zu Potte und das kommt nicht
zum Ausdruck und auf der anderen Seite
haben sie bei bei bei Wagenknecht
sozusagen das ist ja in vieler Hinsicht
wie sozialdemokratische Programmatik aus
den 70er Jahren oder so weiter was in im
im Programm steht und das ist aber auch
nicht erstaunlich weil wir leben in
Zeiten des Umbruchs Transformation
Migration Klima alles mögliche dass man
sich sozusagen zurückbesinnt und dass
man sagt na am Sozialstaat der 70er oder
bei der Übersichtlichkeit war ja nicht
alles verkehrt so besinnen wir uns doch
mal da drauf wieder das kann man zwar
als jetzt rückständig und versteinert
beschreiben aber das es ein Impuls ist
der in solchen Zeiten aufkommt und dass
der dann Anklang findet ist so
erstaunlich wir haben jetzt mehr als 3%
der Sendezeit mit der Partei DIE LINKE
zugebracht ich würde gerne noch mal zum
Parteiensystem zurückkehren und das was
das jetzt bedeutet diese Partei
Neugründungen diese Fragmentierungen
dieses ausdifferenzieren dieses
diversifizieren sind die Volksparteien
endgültig Geschichte ja schon lange nein
ich meine jetzt war ja immer wieder
gesagt vielleicht sch Union versucht hat
wieder etwas gewonnen an an Kraft aber
kann man das jetzt wirklich dann Haken
dran machen zur eigenen Legitimation
benutzen sie weiterhin den Begriff sie
sind aber faktisch am Ende sie können
nicht ein Programm anbieten das ein
derweitartig weites Spektrum hat dass
man
verschiedene Gruppen verschiedene
Milieus in der Gesellschaft auffordern
kann sich unter dem Schirm der Partei zu
versammeln das merken sie auch die
Grünen haben relativ schnell schon drauf
reagiertem sie g hab wir wollen so eine
bündnispartei werden also Bündnis aber
mit der Zivilgesellschaft Organisation
der Zivilgesellschaft aber keine
Volkspartei immer weitere reinholen also
insofern denke ich wird man von den
Volksparteien als einen parteientyp in
aus der Vergangenheit reden und sehen
wie man die neuen Parteien nennen kann
professionalisierte wählerparteien oder
bewegungsparteien oder ähnliches mehr
aber Volkspartei ad ich würde da ein
Fragezeichen dran machen klar der
megatren geht aus auf aus
Differenzierung aber wir haben
eigentlich als Journalisten seit den
90er Jahren leittikel geschrieben und
die Volksparteien verabschiedet und dann
kamen sie doch immer wieder zurück auch
in verschiedenen Konstellationen und
wenn man auf die Landtagswahlen schaut
es gibt immer wieder Situation selbst
die SPD im Saarland mit Frau Redinger
auf einmal merkt man oh dieses
volksparteiengefäß das existiert auch
als ein ein eine identitätstiftende
Brücke innerhalb der Gesellschaft
zwischen Gruppen und W Demokratie
stabilisierend ja absolut natürlich auch
weil Konflikte internalisiert werden und
wenn man sieht wie die CDU sich jetzt
erholt hat das hätte man Friedrich märz
nicht zugetraut aber er hat das
geschafft das ist erstaunlich ich lebe
in Bayern da würden sie wenn sie die CSU
beobachten auch nicht sagen die Zeit der
Volkspartei ist vorbei die ist da
ziemlich
viral und
ich glaube dass die Frage eher ist wem
gehört die Zukunft wer wer definiert
Avantgard oder wer ist progressiv
jahrzehntelang hatte die Linke den
Anspruch auf den Titel wir sind die
progressiven und denkst du progressiv
hieß denkst du links und das hieß
eigentlich Ausbau des Staates Ausbau der
Sozialsysteme und wenn Sie heute den
Begriff des progressiven mal anlegen auf
politische Bewegung dann ist es
definitiv nicht links wenn die Jugend
würde sich heute kein chigevara Hemd
mehr anziehen die hängen sich die ziehen
sich T-Shirts von Elon Musk an
eigentlich die superkapitalisten aus dem
Silicon Valley sind die Helden der
progressiven neuen Generation und da
sieht man wie sich die Dinge verkehren
können und deswegen wäre ich vorsichtig
mit der Prognose also die Volksparteien
sind sind weg und das progressive ist
noch links das ist nicht so ich glaube
das immer so es gibt natürlich diese und
dann gibt es auch die Friday for future
und es gibt alles mögliche also ich
glaube die Jugend ist ist heute sehr
viel weniger homogen als sie zu den
Zeiten von chigevara T-Shirts war aber
ich wollte was anderes sagen und zwar
was meine ich schon ein Problem wird auf
das wir zusteuern in Deutschland ist die
Schwierigkeit die es gibt bei der
Mehrheitsbildung und das ist vollkommen
egal ob man eine Partei Volkspartei
nennt oder nicht Volkspartei
und übrigens auch in Bayern gibt's jetzt
früher war das undenkbar dass es keine
absolute Mehrheit für die CSU gibt jetzt
haben die sich schon drauf eingerichtet
jetzt haben sie zwar die Freien Wähler
mit denen sie dann so tun können als
wäre es eine absolute Mehrheit aber wer
weiß wie lange das noch gut geht also
bei großen Parteien die wir jetzt
aktuelle
Umfragen 14% SPD 13% grüne CDU jetzt
gerade bei 30 aber man weiß auch nicht
was da in paar Monaten ist also das sind
alles Parteien wo man alsoer alles
Umfrage W wo man sagen muss da reichen
auf jeden Fall nicht zwei Parteien aus
um ein Bündnis zu bilden sondern es sind
drei möglicherweise in manchen
Bundesländern sogar vier Parteien
erforderlich um überhaupt eine
parlamentarische Mehrheit zu zu haben
und jetzt schauen wir auf die Ampel und
sehen wie schwierig das ist ein
Dreierbündnis zusammenzuhalten ich will
nicht sagen dass es nur daran liegt dass
es drei Parteien sind das ist daran dass
es gerade so so schlecht läuft aber das
ist sicherlich ein Grund das ist ein
gewohnt so viele Parteien für wir sind
eigentlich gewohnt klare mehr zu haben
in dem klaren Lager denk
m le Lager und diechel sich irgendwie ab
das ist das ist bundesdeutsche Tradition
und jetzt haben wir diese Schwierigkeit
das drei zusammenkommen und darauf muss
man sich einstellen über diese ganze
Frage wie werden künftlich Mehrheiten
stabilisiert das kommt glaub
ich das hat ein Vorteil bildet das ab
was die Gesellschaft lebt und es schafft
ja vielleicht auch Möglichkeiten
Variable zu regieren das kommt doch dann
viel mehr auf die Führung an also wenn
du dann
muss no Mehrheit finden also mus im MS
uns glaube ich her PUs auch an diese
politische Promiskuität erstmal
gewöhnen die in anderen Ländern ja seit
Jahrzehnten üblich ist aber bei uns noch
Neuland na ja fragen Sie mal in
Thüringen nach in Brandenburg oder in
Sachsen da ist es ja schon Realität und
wir haben auch im Bund jetzt eine drei
parteienkoalition
oder ja und ich glaube übrigens um noch
mal auf den äh Herrn Marsen sprechen zu
kommen dass das der einzige strategische
Gedanke ist den er bei der ganzen Sache
sozusagen im Schilde führt ich schließe
mich dem an was Sie gesagt haben ich
glaube nicht dass das Erfolg haben kann
er ist das
bundestagsdirektkandidat mit Pauken und
Trompeten gescheitert in Thüring er hat
kein Charisma und ich weiß nicht ob er
so richtig ein Plan hat aber ich glaube
er hat eine Idee und die Idee ist die
die einer Scharnierfunktion zur AFD er
will die AFD koalitionsfähig machen um
damit maximal Rache zu nehmen an seiner
alten Partei da müsste er zunächst mal
wenn er das schier selbst sein will ja
in den Landtag kommen es könnte aber in
unserem Wahlsystem un Wahlen noch was
ganz anderes passieren wenn man sich
gerade Thüringen nimmt eine ganze Reihe
von Parteien werden da jetzt antreten
die FDP die Grünen sogar die SPD ist
nicht weit von der 5% Grenze weg und die
muss ja nach dem deutschen Wahlrecht
erreicht werden um überhaupt in den
Landtag zu kommen wer da drunter bleibt
fällt weg und dann werden die restlichen
landtagssitze aufgeteilt unter die die
über 5%
haben das heißt wenn jemand selbst weit
weniger als die Hälfte der Wählerstimmen
hat könnte er durch die Sitze im Landtag
ja durchaus die Mehrheit haben das
mathematisch wäre das denkbar also z.B
auch dass der AFD weniger als 40%
genügen um in Thüringer im Thüringer
Landtag im extremf die absolute Mehrheit
zu bekommen das heißt da wäre ja das
Wahlrecht auf der einen Seite das ja
diese 5% Klausel zur Sicherung der
Stabilität 1949 eingeführt in den 50er
eingeführt hat ähm weimmer Verhältnisse
dass er auf der einen Seite auf der
anderen Seite würde es aber dazu führen
dass plötzlich eine Partei ähm an die
Macht kommt die man die viele da nicht
sehen wollen ist da eine große Gefahr
dass das unterschätzt wird was diese
Fragmentierung des Parteiensystems des
der Verfall des Ansehens etablierter
Parteien mit sich bringen könnte nein
warum das wissen ja die Leute ist ja
nicht so dass es ein Geheimnis ist und
am Wahlabend erkennt man hoch das
Wahlrecht sieht ja jetzt ungewöhnliche
Dinge vor und in Thüringen wird ja das
diskutiert im W Kampf und das ist dann
kollektive wensbildung aus meiner Sicht
führt es in Thüringen dazu dass wir
einen Zweikampf zwischen Herrn Fogt und
Herrn höcke erleben werden und die CDU
davon natürlich auch profitieren kann
dass sie sich als Letzter Sachverwalter
der der bürgerlichen Republik
präsentieren kann indem sie diesen
Zweikampf eröffnet und die Menschen in
Thüringen wissen ganz genau was das
Risiko ist und verändern dann ihr
Wahlverhalten und die Dinge sind so in
Bewegung wir wissen nicht was die
wagenknchtpartei da macht die hat die
Bürgermeisterin von Eisenach gewonnen
könnte dort auch die Stimmung noch mal
komplett drehen also da würde ich mal
die Bürger nicht unterschätzen die
laufen nicht blind in so eine Situation
auf einmal wachen sie auf und wir haben
eine absolute Mehrheit der AFD also es
gibt do schon Zulauf zur Linken in
Thüringen also so wie in Berlin
überraschend zur AFD gibt es auch
Überraschung Zulauf zur Linken weil
ramelo als Person sehr viel mehr
Wertschätzung gelegen genießt als die
Partei die er repräsentiert und es kann
durchaus taktisches Verhalten sein sagen
wir gehen da rein wählen machen diese um
zu verhindern dass er faktisch durch
höcke oder Frucht abgelöst wird aber
aber her weim mal was sie ihr Szenario
beruht ja auf dem Grundgedanken dass die
Leute irgendwie AFD aus Protest wählen
und wenn sie dann wissen oh es kann ja
wirklich passieren dass wir ein
Ministerpräsidenten von der AFD haben
dass sie es dann lassen ich glaube das
ist nicht die anderen und dieübertimmen
die
dannu ich ja klar nur gleichzeitig
zeigen alle Umfragen und so weiter dass
es eben doch viele Menschen gibt die gar
nicht mittlerweile jedenfalls in
Thüringen gar keine Angst mehr haben vor
ein AFD
retremisten sind aber die haben halt
nicht mehr diese Abscheu und Empörung
die sie empfinden und und nur denken
provokationshalber drüber nach sondern
sie deswegen kann man sich da nicht so
sicher sein das hat funktioniert
natürlich in Brandenburg in
SachsenAnhalt da wurde jeweils der
starke Ministerpräsident gestärkt aber
in Thüringen haben wir den Sonderfall
dass wir eben ein
Linken mindestens in Thüringen in ein
gemeinsames Bündnis ja so aber das ist
eben deswegen rede ich von der wie von
den Schwierigkeiten von Mehrheitsbildung
die erfordert dass man
kompromissbereiter ist als in der
Vergangenheit und deswegen ist die CDU
die ja also auch gut beraten darüber
nachzudenken zumal es ja vollkommen
widersinnig ist in meinen Augen zu sagen
mit Sarah Wagenknecht kann man
koaliieren aber mit der Linken die in
vielen Fragen längst nicht so
populistisch ist nicht da gibt's aber
einen unvereinbarkeitsbeschluss der muss
ja und sie sehen aber jetzt schon auch
im Bundestag wenn die Partei die BSW da
einzieht und no als Gruppe durch die
Seitentür reingekommen ohne sich an der
Wahl zu beteiligen ohne im
Parteiensystem etabliert zu sein sitzen
sie auf einmal im
Bundestag so als sei die politische
Mitte
passiv als hätte sie keine
Handlungsoption als wäre das sozusagen
jetzt kommen die Populisten von rechts
und links und die Mitte wird einfach
gefressen und muss dann auch sehen wie
sie sich irgendwie noch rettet das
unterschätzt doch völlig das Momentum
dass die politische Mitte auch agieren
kann stellen wir uns mal vor unser
Bundeskanzler würde anfangen zu regieren
würde die migrationskrise lösen ja dann
würde die Stimmung im Lande völlig
anders da würde die die AFD
möglicherweise schnell implodieren wir
haben es in Dänemark gesehen die
Sozialdemokraten haben das Problem
gelöst und damit auch das Problem des
Rechtspopulismus und wer sagt uns denn
nicht dass auf einmal in der politischen
Mitte eine neue Kraft Entfall also ich
wäre da nicht so fatalistisch aber dann
ist die Migrationspolitik von Sarah
wknecht und ihrre Partei ja doch gar
nicht so rechts und extremistisch
sondern rel
cdinie wenn ich sie jetzt gerade noch
mal zemlich genau das was die CDU auch
fort also da wird sicherlich keine
Probleme geben ich meine wenn man auf
die Wirtschafts und die Sozialpolitik
guckt dann auch nicht
ich meine wir haben schon über über VOG
Kulturkampf und so weiter heute geredet
war auch beim Parteitag übrigens relativ
wenig Thema Oscar laontin hat mal einen
kleinen Witz Gendern gemacht bzw gesagt
na ja wenn wer von dem Betrieb tritt als
betriebsratsvorsitzend oder
Gewerkschafter und dann mit Liebe Kolleg
innen so der wird ja ausgelacht aber das
war's dann auch schon so ungefähr also
ich glaub da wird der Pragmatismus den
diese Mehrheitsverhältnisse erfordern
der ist glaube ich so gut wie bei allen
Akteuren vorhanden die spannende Frage
wird das sein was für eine Art von von
von von Regierungskoalition sich dann
bildet und wer davon abhackt sie haben
gerade Mario frugt angesprochen ich find
das schon das der versucht ja quasi aus
der Mitte heraus ins Handeln zu kommen
jetzt und mit höcke sich Modell zu
stellen genau das interess Erben jetzt
gerade in der Gegenwart viele Proteste
viel Wut die sich auf den Straßen weit
macht äh viel wird
ja viele werden zu Aktivisten äußern
ihre Meinung jetzt werden sogar noch
Parteien gegründet neue Parteien
gegründet das klingt ja eigentlich nach
gelebter Demokratie was wir gerade
erleben Ja und Nein
äh es gibt ja diesen Spruch wenn und da
ist die migrationskrise natürlich der
Elefant im Raum wenn die politische
Mitte die migrationskrise nicht löst
dann löst die migrationskrise die
politische Mitte und das erleben wir wir
erleben es ja nicht nur in Deutschland
wir erleben es in ganz Europa wir leben
ehrlich gesagt jetzt auch in den USA das
ist ja ein Wahlkampf der geht nur um die
Grenze in Texas so wie der im Moment
sich da anbahnt und
äh und das ist natürlich
ähm zumindest in auf der hoffnungsseite
ein Element wo man sagen kann ja gut du
hast eine Handlungsoption politische
Mitte egal ob es jetzt grüner roter
schwarzer oder gelber ist und wir sehen
am Beispiel Dänemark dass das gelingen
kann auch andere Länder schaffen das und
dann ist doch die Aufsplitterung einer
Parteienlandschaft oder die Vitalität
einer Gesellschaft eher eine positive
Nachricht aber wir erleben ja auch
derzeit nicht nur zum Glück nicht nur
Wut auf den Straßen sondern wir erleben
ja auch Großdemonstration
hunderttausende jedes Wochenende die für
die Demokratie für das bestehende System
demonstrieren die bisher sehr still
geblieben sind die die Straßen erst den
coronaleugnern und dann den anderen
wütenden Bevölkerungsgruppen überlassen
haben und jetzt hat sich das gewendet
das spricht für Herrn weimersthe von der
Mitte die aufwacht und die sagt
Entschuldigung können wir uns auch mal
zu Wort melden und sagen dass wir hinter
diesem und zu diesem System stehen
trotzdem ähm meine ich dass also oder
die Frage ist das müssen deboskopen am
Ende beantworten aber mein mein Gefühl
ist dass es nicht nur nicht mehr nur die
Ränder sind von denen wir sprechen wenn
es um systemgegnerschaft geht sondern
dass dieses ähm dass diese
Unzufriedenheit dieses ähäh dieses
schlecht reden die grundsätzliche Kritik
an unserer freiheitlich demokratischen
Grundordnung bis in Bürger ichten
hineinesickert ist und dass das System
ausgehült wird von ihnen jedenfalls die
Gefahr besteht dass bestimmte Dinge
salonfähig sind die vor 20 Jahren
undenkbar waren und das ist die Gefahr
das die Gefahr ist dass die Ränder
ausgreifen die Gefahr der Unterwanderung
und so weiter sich reingraben bis in die
bürgerliche Mitte und das müssen wir
beobachten das beobachtet der Verfassung
diese Mitte ja eigentlich ambivalent ist
einerseits die Gefahr
dass Gedankengut antidemokratisches
Gedankengut ein Zickert auf der anderen
Seite wie wir haben jetzt die
Demonstration genannt dass diese Mitte
durchaus Demokratie stabilisierend nach
wie vor
wirkt ja ich bin ja immer nicht so ganz
glücklich mit diesem Bild von den bösen
Rändern und der behaglichen Mitte das
ist zwar eine sehr populäre
Sicht auf die Dinge in Deutschland aber
ich weiß jetzt nicht was z.B an den
freien wähern meinetwgen oder auch am
Bündnis Sara Wagenknecht
demokratiefeindlich sein soll ich meine
demokratiefeinde gibt es in der AFD das
ist relativ offensichtlich es gibt's ja
auch bei den Freien Wählern wenn
eiwanger erklärt wir müssen die
Demokratie uns von denen da wiederholen
und er ist ein Repräsentant der da oben
dann ist das so und dann erinnere ich
bitteschön entstehen Nationalsozialismus
der war nicht an den rändnern der war in
der bürgerlichen Mitte in der Mitte der
Gesellschaft und das ist das Problem
dass wir in der Tat haben wenn ihre
Hoffnung unterstützten die Mitte nicht
sagt wir wären uns dagegen ja wir
besinnen uns auf demokratische straturen
demokratische Kultur nur die Demokratie
gibt uns die Möglichkeit in bestimmter
Art und Weise zu leben und gleichzeitig
auch durch die Vielfalt von Politik dazu
beizutagen dass Wohlstand gesichert wird
dass soziale Ausgeglichenheit herrschen
könnt dass die Gesellschaft ökonomisch
effektiv ist und das auch Frieden gacht
wird aber dann man braucht kein
Feindbild in dieser Mitte ne aber aber
warum warum passiert denn das alles
gerade sozusagen im Moment nicht wir
sind in der riesigen Phase der
Veränderung vielleicht noch mal auf den
politischen Inhalt
sprechen zu kommen
machen eine Haushalt eine Fiskalpolitik
die andere Länder andere Finanzminister
die Hände über den Kopf zusammen
schlagen würden also das ist ja eine
Phase in der es eigentlich halt einfach
wirklich einen aktiven und
investierenden Staat braucht und einer
der Kredite aufnimmt weil er glaubt dass
er diese Kredite später wieder
zurückzahlen kann weil sie die
Investition lohnen also das ist gerade
ein unheimlicher Beschleuniger dass wir
eine Regierung haben die sich über
diesen Haushalt sozusagen zerlegt und
auch noch kürzt in einer Zeit in der es
eigentlich an allen Ecken und Enden
Bedarf gibt ja das war vielen Dank dass
Sie das übernommen haben für mich Herr
Puschner die überleidungsmoderation zur
morgigen phönixrunde ich bedanke mich
jetzt erstmal für heute bei ihen bei
Helene poprowski bei Wolfram Weimer bei
Gero Neugebauer und bei Sebastian
Puschner Liebe Zuschauerin liebe
Zuschauer morgen in der phöxrunde
Schlagabtausch im Bundestag kriegt die
Ampel noch die Kurve Mittwoch ist
Generaldebatte aktuell sind phöx der Tag
mit Julia Grimm darin eben heute auch
der
Bundeshaushalt 2024 der vom
Finanzminister eingebracht wurde und wie
gesagt morgen Generaldebatte bleiben Sie
bei
[Musik]
uns